je suis une femme ordinaire
grand-mère qui désirent que son travail
ait du sens et donc c'est pour ça que je
suis content de travailler au service
catholique des funérailles qui est un
travail dur mais tellement riche puisque
vous êtes vraiment au coeur de la vie la
mort celle que c'est le sens de la vie
alors déjà dans les paroisses quand
j'étais avec mes jeunes enfants je
m'occupais des familles en deuil c'est
toujours quelque chose sur lequel
j'étais porté et le 15 mai 99 j'ai perdu
un ami il devait venir dîner à la maison
lui est mort d'un accident de moto sa
femme est resté seize mois à l'hôpital
avec aux opérations l'enterrement s'est
déroulée
et en l'absence donc de martine donc de
l'épouser
et c'était un choix très difficile à
faire on avait un ami qui était
caméraman géante n 2 qui a filmé la
cérémonie c'est moi qui ai dû prendre la
décision de filmer pour martin on a
donné cette cassette à l'époque pour
martine sachant qu'elle en ferait ce
qu'elle voudrait
alors en fait à 46 ans j'ai repris des
études de théologie donc lhi heures à
paris à la catho c'est ça m'a passionné
et je voulais absolument trouver un
travail en étroite concordance avec ma
manière d'être et mon baptême donc je
suis allé à l'évêché est depuis en
aiguille c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontré christian cacqueray qu'il m'a
proposé ce poste je suis pompes funèbres
à part entière mais c'est vrai que on a
cette étiquette s'est risqué à laetoli
des funérailles qu'on revendique 1 parce
que je veux me bon baptême de cette
manière mon rôle est d'accompagner les
familles et les écouter en priant certes
mais d'abord d'être à leur service je
décharge des familles de toutes les
questions administratives juridiques et
financières en fait donc lorsqu'elles
sortent de ce bureau elles peuvent et
elles ont l'esprit libre pour s'occuper
d'organiser de prévoir de choisir les
textes en fonction d'être aimé qui
viennent de perdre et puis donc elles
sont disponibles pour être avec l'équipe
des familles en deuil où le prêtre donc
vraiment c'est un vrai travail d'équipé
l'un porté par confiner rers ont fait
ces trois temps la mise en bière est
lavé le corps ce qu'on appelle chez nous
l'a dit au visage ou là on peut prier en
intimité avec la famille est très
souvent ce qu'on a rencontrés durant
l'entretien
après il ya un mais sous laon n'est que
pompes funèbres
mais par contre moi j'insiste parce que
je le choisis c'est vrai quelques
familles ont remercié parce que vous
avez des petits enfants de voir le
maître de cérémonie commune et ça les a
un peu surpris et donc c'est vrai que ça
permet une intimité en tête
des fortes relations ont cuit après au
cimetière très souvent donc je n'aime
une prière si la famille me demande est
ce assez c'est sûr que c'est un vrai
accompagnement et ça correspond un
tableau entre eux j'aime bien lorsqu'il
ya une des funérailles ou norel défunt
donc les quatre porteurs et moi même on
s'incline devant le cercueil mais s'il
est une car ici je leur demande de
s'incliner devant l'autel et ça c'est
vrai que les familles catholiques trouve
que c'est des petits gestes importants
et donc com - pour moi l'eucharistie
c'est quand même le sommet de la foi
chrétienne je trouve que voilà aimé
panther aime le faire
mon péché d'orgueil c'est quand les gens
disent ah c'est le service catholique
des funérailles je savais bien ça c'est
assez amusant et c'est vrai que bon on
aime la reconnaissance donc le fait de
savoir que on fait bien notre boulot
c'est toujours agréable
comme j'ai la chance d'avoir des
bénévoles avec nous on peut vraiment
libéré la parole le stress l'émotion
on forme une équipe interne qui nous
permet quand même de beaucoup se
soulager en fait elle a envoyé un mail
elle avait une mauvaise adresse l'ami un
petit tirer alors qu'il fallait un point
je vous redis une fois et vraiment je
les remercie beaucoup les bénévoles sont
là pour accueillir les familles mais
elles mettent beaucoup puisque c'est
chez elle que je décharge c'est chez
elle que je pique mes colères puisque
c'est pas devant la police ou devant les
familles et donc tous mes petits ennuis
elles l'entendent et elle les comités et
elles sont toujours sourire et ça
vraiment c'est le secret de christian tu
as créé d'avoir mélangé des salariés des
bénévoles et d'avoir cet esprit là il ya
quelques années j'ai reçu une carte qui
m'a conformément touchés
parce que la personne m'a dit que à
travers moi l'a vu le visage du christ
donc
je ne sais pas si voilà en fait j'en ai
jamais parlé mais ça m'a vraiment
profondément touché
on veut juste être professionnel ça
c'est très important avant tout pour
leur rendre le service qu'elles viennent
chercher et mais en plus ma satisfaction
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive fermé sans un
sourire et qui arrive à sourire malgré
les preuves parce que
on agit en sérénité et avec le cresson